okay four people joining this livestream
this is another piece of designing
microcontroller functionality for the
next version of language and you told me
to look at the prototype build and do
what with it I indicate page just type
in microcontrollers you find a gate page
to it and there should be an updated
guide page this is not getting focused
here for some strange reason it's really
weird oh you know what happened this
didn't have well huh okay hopefully this
is the right version um just a second
there's some bug here you know what
that's really bad bug is that anybody
from project management here
okay I'm gonna have to type something
for this bug okay all right let's see no
it's not gonna be there Steven it's not
the normal source it's a packet source
it's aware of where or how much push to
get it the built documentation oh okay
microcontroller the guy
the third one obviously you should tell
somebody that that searching sequence is
wrong okay so right now just in front of
you dare you see there is two heading
says deploying models but that's just
because an intermediary state we're in
right now okay okay the things that you
pushed for is upload microcontroller
code and generate microcontroller code
okay okay those are new guide pages I'm
sorry reference pages and if you open to
details there's hardly any examples yet
but
we went over this in great detail last
time um you wanted it this way in a lisp
structure you it happened when I left a
meeting so I just found out yesterday
from super why did we want that I don't
know you wanted it's a mapping it says
you know you you want to test that for
fun Association a 0 goes to type analog
but the other thing is also that the
system and the mapping is in the list
it's a pair why isn't this something
like in the whole Association one of the
elements is system arrow and then the
SAU
no no system is way too important ok
this is what why is it enough okay as
opposed to a third argument that's what
we had initially as the third argument
remember that the design you suggested
we had it as the second argument that
was played into two what was split into
two if you go to the top look at the
call box at the top okay so what you had
here sis come a microcontroller mm-hmm
that's what you that's what you added
when I had left a meeting yes you know
last time you insisted to have them in a
list not sure why but you did okay yes
because you you suggested that we have
the microcontroller code data feedback
into as the first argument sorry the
Michael Tarwater
code that that results from generate
microcontroller code that's why yeah
what did you understand I do
but it doesn't have to be that way
anyway you know it's just it says that
you can take code there is the first
argument - there's another possible
first argument that's distinguishable
for sure no I certainly distinguishable
but I mean then you kind of um okay okay
so what else do we have to talk about
here so that's that then there's the
entity's super where can we see them
again
yeah go to the tutorial and the
tutorials page on top yeah just right on
top top right yeah and and the last one
supported microcontrollers very nice is
that what you had in mind that's exactly
what I had in mind
exactly what I had in mind so this has
registered the entities in an entity
store correct yes so the three entity
types microcontroller target
microcontroller vendor and
microcontroller family beautiful um what
are those weird things in there and the
microcontroller family names yep because
yeah that is the flash sighs the flash
memory sighs so in that family there'll
be 32gb atmega 32:8 atmega sixteen eight
it just stands for that what what is the
angle brother how's it usually written
it's in stuff that's a placeholder for
32 16 8 4 and so on it's either got
three to eight atmega 16 8 1 6 8 and so
on so how do people usually do it emits
like x86 will be you know so shouldn't
that be more of them what do you do you
want this should
B to 16 and 32 B yeah why separated out
in microcontroller families yes so if
you take that family and list the
targets one out that that would be that
Magus 32 eight will be one of them so
shouldn't that be it okay so listen
listen what you need is the entity
classes here okay
just like you have a specific country
you know Switzerland or something and
then you have the class of countries
that are in I don't know the Schengen
area or something did you get what I'm
saying
mmm okay so okay so instead of so that
is a class of microcontrollers right so
that that can be handled as an entity
class in the entity system okay then the
actual family shouldn't that be atmega
32:8 I would think so I mean at the
actual other than is it that's a class
of okay go ahead what we're gonna say so
atmega 32:8 comes in different packages
and that's part of that family
oh so they're many atmega328 yes okay so
that's a family so the actual family is
32:8 and there's a different item they
call 6860 yes and there's a class which
is atmega you know Star ate at mega star
you for that correct yes so that mega
star ate can have different packages at
Megas 32:8 can have different packages
at mega 16 it can be different packages
but why we put them as a families they
all have the same instruction set so
what you see as a family all those
microcontrollers have the same
instruction set okay well maybe the name
microcontroller family is wrong maybe
it's a super family or something did you
get what I'm saying I mean so in other
words if if the if if if in fact you
know whatever it is you know atmega but
you you can evaluate this and see what
happens if
because this one doesn't require any
hardware you know I think just evaluate
those inputs there um I'm sorry what am
I supposed to be doing here
you can evaluate any one of those inputs
like this and the entity list microphone
family you can evaluate that but you you
need to put needs microcontroller kit
before that yeah if you want now you can
take say for example the first one and
ask for targets it'll tell all the
different microphone okay so I should be
able to take this and then say targets
yes yeah beautiful
okay that's now out okay so what are
these these are entity these are
microcontroller target entities yeah
these are specific microcontrollers so
these are the specific microcontrollers
microcontroller other way you need to
fix the fact that that is a multi-word
thing you have to ask somebody how to do
that yeah yeah yeah so this is my first
iteration I know the label yes I'll get
to that because right now I just
duplicated it I'll get to this okay and
the way these underscores work it's
probably not what the common names want
to be they probably want to have spaces
in there unless unless the underscore is
what's the what the industry-standard
name of the object is no no yeah it's
not yeah it's a space yeah okay so so
that's that's the common name is what
you're giving there the entity name
might have an underscore in it right the
entity standard name might have an
underscore in it yes yes okay yes but
now this this thing where you say
microcontroller family the main
objection here is only this F thing is
that industry standard to call it air
for did you know it's not it's something
we came up with yes thanks for 32 eight
you see those there at me
32:8 what is X then yeah so if you go to
80 yeah just pick that and ask for
targets you'll see there all the options
but I don't Stan
X is what's the difference why are you
calling an angle bracket F what what do
you mean by angle bracket F it's a
placeholder for different of flash
memories flash memory sizes okay so you
made that up
yes I did okay I don't think it's the
right thing I mean I it's it's okay so
why don't you just call this at megastar
eight okay I mean and similarly eighty
tiny star or you could just call this at
mega space eight because that's the name
of a family but what's the industry
standard name for a family okay I just
picked it up from the database if you
look at atmega328 it just tells it this
is the instruction set for and I
understand that but when people are
referring generically to a star eight
object okay as you're doing here these
are all things with the with the number
eight in them what do people in the
industry call that collection okay so so
you're aggregating them to a higher
level than people in the industry
typically aggregate them is that correct
you know all these have the same data
sheet so on the data they'll say that
all atmega328 backslash atmega one six
eight atmega8 eight all the year so on
the data sheet they list the specific
things here Zacarias okay so we need a
notation so I think atmega either you
know star eight makes sense to me okay
Roger do you have a comment I think
that's okay okay this looks nice I was
more asking because you are the one with
experience of naming commissions for
entities and yeah right well I want to
explain to you guys there are two names
for an entity its standard name which is
its canonical name that is a you know
that is typically camelcase
string and for which that underscore is
not magnificent okay it's acceptable but
not wonderful and the making sense
yes okay and the second thing is it's
common name extracted with the function
common name if you needed to which is
it's print name okay which can have
spaces in it and all kinds of stuff
making sense
where's the common name used in these
yellow boxes oh that's the common name
so let me show you an example if I say
UK for example okay that will say United
Kingdom I can now can have a space in it
common name can have a space in it yes
that's correct
but here a name cannot that is correct
and standard name in a pinch can have
things like underscores in it but it's
preferably does not have those things in
it okay look did you get what I'm saying
yes yes okay well this is cool all right
what else should we look at this looks
very nice I think there was this yeah we
got two now we have additional things
that we haven't yet looked at okay hold
on let me just let me just look at
something here um okay that's all it
says all right yeah because I did yeah
we can add much more we can add
operating voltage of clock frequency and
so on but I just duplicated what we had
in microcontroller targets and make it
much richer um
um okay don't forget what do you do
clock frequency things to put units in
and so on yeah they already have units
no okay wonderful okay what else should
we look at here go back to the m2 might
that one yes yep so what we have looked
at now is embed microcontroller code
microcontroller code data and
microcontroller targets right those are
the main new thought where should we
look at microcontroller targets that's
what that's what became the entity types
oh I see I see I see my control targets
is an option name this is a different
way of giving that list of what possible
targets are using the entity and now we
have to look up use the lookup framework
for entities to find what are possible
targets fine okay so then you're going
to document that as an entity type
alright so we should add that you should
talk to Alan about how to nip that into
the collection of all the entity types
and notice that entity types as of this
version are getting their own
documentation pages okay and so by the
way for example that means you could
link so yeah go ahead
the name upload sounds so much like a
web browser it doesn't let me tell me
what it should be I'm not wedded to that
I mean you tell me what it should be
well I think it could it doesn't need to
be up or down load it just needs to be
load but it also generates the
microcontroller code if you're having
having this discussion can't because the
last time towards the end when we were
discussing this you mentioned that embed
code only does one thing but the
original reason why I called it
microcontroller embed code was because
embed code does both code generation and
also moving into a particular location
now it does not we based on the third
argument when it has the third argument
it does I see okay okay all right you
are bringing up something which I am NOT
big occasion okay all right first for us
that connection port was that location
no it's not in the built Edison or you
can go to microcontroller yeah you can
go to all right you're making a good
argument for calling it microcontroller
in that code yeah and I think it should
just duplicate embed code define what if
it doesn't give the third argument is it
gonna just a it's binary crud isn't it
that it's sent so if it doesn't give the
third argument in some microcontrollers
automatically it will it will it will go
through and and our and embed the code
sorry I notice on the third argument
here which is actually the second
argument in what we're doing here right
um well okay so you're making an
argument here you're making an argument
if it's with the analogy with embed code
you should make you should get rid of
that list which I incorrectly perhaps
introduced right the second argument is
the analog of saying Java or something
as exactly thing and then the third
argument is where it goes what I'm
saying is if you remove the second
argument I'm sorry the third argument if
we remove the destination what embed
code does is to make a UI that gives you
the thing to to copy/paste am i making
sense
no it'll give you the microcontroller
core data because it
can give that one too but it has to it
also has properties associated with that
code as Stephen is talking about in bad
card yes sir yeah that's what I'm
referring to so if the third argument is
not oh yeah embed code gives the source
code right yeah
in both cases in our case we return this
data object right you get the source
code to Stephen it's just a URL to point
to it I'm totally confused you're saying
if you remove that good argument no I'm
saying what we should do for
microcontroller it should return
microcontroller data right
microcontroller code data correct I
think that's and that's consistent what
you said if you give the two argument
for embed code it gives you a link but
that link gives you the source code
you're basically removing you're right
this should be the two argument embed
code form should give you back
microcontroller code data the three
argument one should deploy it to a two
exactly why or something so if you look
if you if you click that that ember and
and if you click that and change that to
new microcontroller embed code new I
also worked out this design you'll see
in the details how this will okay it's
all the same yeah what it what are you
showing here yeah so if you want to
specific that specific thing here you
don't need that you don't need the third
the third argument what is in the third
argument yes the connection port but
some microcontrollers the programmer
will automatically detect the connection
port and and and embed the code so for
those microcontrollers I included this
connection port going to none if you
just want the to generate the code but
you know one thing that would be good is
when you don't have Hardware hooked up
that it just returns to the code yes
exactly so what I'm saying is in the
case where you just say microcontroller
embed code with two arguments okay two
arguments then you're saying return
microcontroller code data that's right
that's what you should do
did you get what I'm saying yes
okay and then that microcontroller code
data can be interrogated to get byte
byte arrays and so on out of it if
necessary if you give a third argument
and the third argument is a naked string
that just says dev TTY whatever that
will be assumed to be the connection
port is that correct yes right now there
is another thing here let's just ask
this fine point but you know even when
you give the third argument through
returns microcontroller control code
data but it also maintains the fact that
it's connected you know that it's that
it's loaded so I'm saying you can see an
indication that it succeeded in the code
dektor yes yes so you want to return
from microcontroller embed code you want
to return the code data object come what
may come what may but but with different
indicators if you don't like it greens
and reds and all that kind of thing
exactly okay sounds sensible to me okay
so so this is the microcontroller yes so
there was another fine point registered
so he because in originally we had embed
micro controller code embed code is
better okay okay let me just show you
one thing here umm yeah the other reason
yeah let me show you one thing okay so
this is the new mechanism function
compiled export function compile export
library and so on this is the new
mechanism for the compiler also we have
separate export functions for what for
all of these are like versions of export
looks to me unfortunately they're
somewhat subtle to put it mildly no I
believe you I certainly believe that um
and some of these things are bizarre
versions of X I mean yes ultimately this
I mean this does compilation right yeah
I mean it's possible that one day we
could just get away with using export
with various no I believe you
hey I can see how many things that you
might want to control in if to get it
flexible enough so okay so one of the
things that this does let's look at this
you know so then you need a string a
byte array version so the - yes but they
do different things
see there's binary versions as a son
that's basically assembly code and as
object code I see okay so byte arrays
object coder sir yes export allows both
of them I mean it's possible when we
have this all working that we will just
be able to take a compiled code function
yeah and and use that what I was looking
for was the target the mechanism for ah
see wait a minute oh this is an old
version this is before today sorry um I
have to update this I wants to show you
the mechanism that it has for target
architectures right and there was one
other thing there if you go back to my
yep today there's one thing that's
relatively small but you might have
opinions about which is systems
connections model that relates to sort
of our whole control framework control
control design systems framework it's
just a better way to knit together and
wire together system models but more
flexible than what we had because the
original control framework had things
like feedback connect and parallel
connect but what is this this is a
general graph it has a guide page in the
in the regular basis ruffridge ref it is
a regular source guide is a relative
connections model yes it's a model of
system connections systems yes
you
I see so this is the analog of
serial/parallel this that and the other
this generalizes all of those because it
gives you to the general connection
topology alright let me just show you
one thing here um so this has a target
system option that is set to a system ID
here right now I'm not necessarily
advocating this I'm just saying this is
a different mechanism so what you're
doing is you're providing the target as
a second argument which is I think the
right thing to do for an embed code I'm
just thinking through what that looks
like here it's fine
yeah because the first argument is what
the second argument is where and now so
to speak yeah okay all right what's your
point
yeah so the reason we want you because
when we generate code for these systems
we don't want to just munch them into
just one function so when we have this
multiple subsystems the code but the
coil equivalent code is also going to be
different subroutines in the C or C code
the source code yes but how do you do
what are the entry points to the
different subroutines
what do you so so that's it okay if you
look at an example little down
what does Eve I think I even have an
example of C so or you can go all the
way down to applications I think where I
have a application example for this or
forget the okay so this is oh I see I
see I see I see I see I see this says
but these things don't have named ports
because they're not matrices so they
have just numbered ports right system
and port that's how it's referred to
system one
position one can I ask you how that
corresponds to the way ports work in
your own that's I think it might be
worth looking at how those work because
I think what you have might be somewhat
similar to what exists there yes okay
applications yes so we want to put
embedded systems connection into a
microcontroller Wow that's pretty
sophisticated okay all right so the
state space model which has some kind of
two-step lagging stuff it just takes the
inputs and it's moving average so that
defiance the three subsystems yes okay
then you then you wire them together
okay great and that stays it needs to
stay as a wrapper like that because it
cannot always reduce to you know it's
unreduced great and I mean it's that
picture a realistic picture is that
picture this is I think is going can't
okay so yeah I understand but this
reminds me a lot of net graph well the
salsa sort of very similar problem yeah
and encouragingly it works the same way
so the only difference is the port
mechanism okay yeah I'm saying and also
another thing that you might want to get
so we haven't we haven't come back to
work and control for many years as you
know okay so there are many things to be
could and should do eventually okay so I
mean you you want my input on this
function my only comment is the second
case of net graph for you're using named
things rather than numbered things I
also want to support
we don't have names we don't have names
because we could potentially that's a
control thing there we have system model
labels which can use strings and images
so we don't really refer to them if it's
a string we can we we don't want to do
that now super because it has many
concepts right but I'm just saying for
the future you might want this case as
well yes yes we do but that's what I was
kind of beginning outside there many
things that need sort of a TLC in
control right now in in terms of the way
ok so the net port I see you should just
read this through about how ports work
here because I'm wondering whether the
enth layers but see they worry about
things like computing gradients because
if you can't do the fitting without the
gradient I understand I'm just wondering
whether there's a notation here that's
different from your notation that
represents the port of a of a subsystem
effectively or a layer in that case I
don't think so I don't think it's
incompatible by the way you might just
for the heck of it you might want to
refer back and forth between that graph
and this thing as a last kind of
throwaway you know reference see also
yeah this looks perfectly reasonable to
me it's pretty nifty ok one more thing
yes
final thing yep ok get back to my yeah
yep external type signature mm-hmm so I
think that we haven't there's a bunch of
projects that's moved on since this was
originally crafted and I think we have
standard types for instance numeric
array has standard types
where did external type signature I mean
that that's part of the that's part of a
bunch of these things it's part of the
external function mechanism and so on
isn't it yes yes it's part of the input
ports and output ports even the system
model it's part of everything basically
what are you talking about external type
what what kind of thing an external type
signature be like energy sixteen or
something or what go to the page good
get it to the page I know this we have
we didn't document it because it's
documented for embed code but yeah it's
similar or embed om okay why is this so
slow what is it doing
oh great
his rules mapping to external types an
embedded code what in an embedded code
that doesn't make any sense
oh boy this is something we have to look
at in connection with a compiler what's
your point about it right now
yeah so for us if you say external type
to the details the penultimate one
external type goes to that particular
type it tells the returning type of that
function for example in serial we want
to say that the date they're coming in
is of type int or real and so on and so
we'll use that data type in the source
code for that what's in what source code
in the generated source code okay fine
this is a this is an option to
microcontroller embed code is that
correct yes okay but I think that we
shouldn't use the lowercase int and
things like that should we know we
should use integer 16 and all those
kinds of things
oh yeah wait wait a sec wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
external type signature the thing that
it says here oh boy it you and I yeah I
looked at this and I thought this was
because the other one we have to make a
mental jump from that those canonical
names to this so you just said what is
what is this directly um
Sorry Sorry Sorry
this here is the raw external type
specification right yes and what are you
suggesting that we use a curated type
like integer like one of our actual type
type objects no no I'm just saying the
used to just like oats yeah that's so
even in microcontroller embed code it's
used we can say external type signature
goes to int or you want to use this why
do you want to do that int is is what in
what language is int in the source right
now we only generating source code in C
okay but I'm saying that what you should
do maybe you can support int as an
alternative but I think you also should
support you know things like integer 16
and so on yeah I don't yet but yeah but
we can do that yes I'm I'm all in favor
us doing both because then there's a
group of users if one yeah you know the
wrong thing Ryan so so we should use the
types that are already specified for
binary read list
how much are being specified on the
compiler I think the most systematic
such list today exists for numeric array
fine just for one second I really need
to go the relationship between this and
the compiler so the compiler is
generating potentially C object code
right or it's generating I mean it could
be generating actual C code but it
support full C code these
microcontrollers are not it's okay so
the one question is is there an LLVM to
microcontroller transformation yeah it's
very sparse okay fine it's not yeah
that's not much I have not seen much
effort in that direction okay
I can't imagine our compiler projects
can tackle microcontrollers anytime soon
okay fine no problem just asking um okay
it's happily chat tackling CPUs yes and
maybe the net the the known that stuff
will tackle TP use and so on and
GPUs yes I think the old VM stuff can
tackle some GPU stuff all right I think
we're done here
anything more I think this is it you
know we want to put it together now as
tight as we can and maybe we do a kind
of a wrap-up because we should talk
about some some of the following
projects and all that - yep
okay and how to tell people about it
all good actually it's very nice very
nice oh I didn't know what was happening
on this and this is all great all right
- thank you all and see you soon and
have a good trip super